as good a season as these had going back
to maybe the 2010
move on with the hitter head to the key
one out of six one two we're both here
it was definitely finishing around the
rim good enhanced by Rajan dos nice
boots finish the alley-oop footbridge on
my Stephenson I thought he did an
outstanding job
[Applause]
a lot of teams say they want to run but
when fatigue set practice and going
against and here's a guy that coach
Pitino had to make a decision who's
going to play didn't play us together
but we both had to buy in for the first
time in his career came off the bench on
Wednesday night shot block Kyle coos but
just to the game Laker defense whose
left left wide open which Don Arden here
he got beat to the left but did not foul
him continue to pursue this again of
discipline backdoor coos ba one of the
first slam
Thank You basketball you zone ronzo bah
as in pictures do not sit instead forces
it under the clothes my boy there was
little room for error their story to the
pylons oh look out - coos - Man 3
[Applause]
daddy made his mom the gonna karate made
that we lead has disappeared they still
lead but only by three what happened to
Forbes they hurry shaggy hold or did you
fail what they offer you though multiple
guys that can just throw it down
baseline move well
snoring if there's only two teams
holding a bonus under a hundred points
one is this different noticing the
it beats the buzzer knocks down the
three lean to half-ton the American
Express halftime is next on TNG slam
later sports in affair Lakers tap it
here they come on the break the
transition and coos just attached the
roads in it hammers warm house to give
the Minnesota Koosman launches a great
Fitzie night a NBA Kyle Kuzma three of
his ten points for Lakers in double
figures let us the wolves with a
one-point lead at halftime 25 points for
Derrick Rose the flush
extort Rondo kicks it out whose muffin
tray
want a title with LBJ back in 2016 so
each other very well spoiled by Koosman
here he goes all the way throw it down
who stepped in the lane and knocked the
ball free easy deuces he gets out and
says come get somebody's touch the
errant box drive to Koopa scoop has had
it the elite suggests he percent trouble
and the Lakers are going for our one
still shocked yeah a 24 year old son you
look 30 deep frozen out Koosman running
the floor throws it down and one of the
quickest paces in the NBA is just high
contact and then trust your receivers
sextant to the basket clock whose mo
with another rejection jetty Osman shot
won't go Thompson's tip misses and Magee
[Music]
[Applause]
the yogi rebound put it up and passing
the basketball that's what I told the
quiet off for Dallas
Ingram operating on top surveys the
floor gives it to gurus yes
and starting to feel it isn't he a fella
make the right way LeBron with the steel
up - kruseman
time-outs first
discipline security of months for them
whose mother for three got it pile
Kuzma has another bucket look at that
shot over the corner of the backboard by
cooze from he is nothing but bottom kept
his eye on the target knew he had to put
a little extra arc on it to get it over
the corner and rebound his [ __ ] steal
by hey CP made that what happened lazy
pass on the outlet k CP steps in gets to
steal and the assist Dwayne and k CP
steps in missed your sister that's the
way you attack the basket so well and if
we take care of business and play like
we want to play that will be our
recruiting tool the fact that you can
come play with some winners and Coles
was on his way to trying to be a winner
getting that extra rebound Michigan he
was he was co-captain at Michigan a
Memphis at Golden State who's not all by
himself harden fell down he was guarding
Kuzma on a switch has to give up the
dribble shot clock to three crucial loss
control has to heave it and scores
[Applause]
foodstuff please were just a moment ago
he's got 12 of his 22 here in the third
with that incredible
he's with the shot clock running down
13 minutes seven points six rebounds
good recovery there by kuzmic who's
behind the tribe a mix up number five
k'sia with the strikers huge question
see the guy you want to build
[Applause]
look at Koosman not getting his shot
challenge as he goes through the whole
end I mean flushing Victor Oladipo
missed those games and I'll be it
against the lighter schedule his
teammates held it down whose boy at the
basket and he draws a foul
when
[Music]
sighs enough Jackson
kakuzu killing its foul in the last two
minutes
well that should be free throws now
Jackson a moment ago another look at the
step back my coos and right in front of
the King's Bench the West they killed
this Alexander knocked out of it
long range jump Josh to his mother he's
going downhill he's going all the way
he's storing her now he scored that one
that was on the attack
Oh Chandler was there good defense so
it's Oh a pad for Kuzma somehow he
controls it stores four and a half to
play Kuzma default a gallon are dead
Oh Tony smells it down well because her
John because Cruz is such a threat and a
chance at a three-point another look at
coos setting up who Liam's for the home
as he goes right past got an RIT bid on
the three-point I say well what's the
different between Lonzo ball can Andre
Drummond well one guy has to shoot it to
make us go absolutely
Kuzma beautiful fake got Griffin on the
speed big block on Reggie Miller my
friend
mine
[Music]
that can really heat up and knock down
shots Oh get shooters on the floor and
call the roll Galloway
a new career-high 41 and he's going for
42 a clinic and the fans raining down
coos from the stands here at Staples Wow
4 for 20 in the game a couple of nights
ago he put up 500 shots and then came
out with 21 coos look nobody talking or
at least not talking at the right time
and they opened the gate and coos right
down the gut for the flush he's got 8
the game try the dog the charge got
knocked down but got up clicking up to
get the rebound who's not with a leather
boy accepted goes all the way for the
flush look out throw it down up gift
three gets the rebound and then pushes
it all the way up the floor nobody
really stops the ball so he gets an easy
play
[Music]
[Applause]
getting it off of the in violence
playing right here okay go up and fake
approach and give NBA guys wide open
shots which he just got on both both the
first two possessions right those were
like dare shots like that's got to be a
nominee for worse fast break of the year
Guzman straight on three that's good
Kuzma four three-pointers make plays one
on one on the top Nene
no no knocks down a long ball Lakers up
beautiful move by Kuzma soft hands in
guzman he's in that old Carmilla spot
that bully boss bus and also sport team
for Harris Ando checked into the
ballgame Kuzma having a huge first-half
this amazing always hot of the bench
you're not ready for him he was too far
away on the help and you can't beat one
one the other way to swap hi
Stephenson could be getting worse but
dead and one
yeah Jimmy Butler just hit that floor oh
[Music]
he wide open he was screaming Howard
literally screaming for it UV we've
heard him over here
[Music]
luckily we got here
[Applause]
Donovan a Koosman Vogon unable to get
the fault Donovan with the rebound
looking up the chase and Tatum Ali
day to the coupe's but nothing like a
Celtics to a Lakers unable to get it
fall possibilities
[Music]
longest last names of the NBA 1:05 98
of both the Clippers and San Antonio but
that could change tonight because
they're getting beat right now the Kuzma
with an emphatic stop out of the timeout
it's a great drive by Koosman finished
but we never wanted to double-team him
and we tried very hard never to put two
guys on the ball
[Music]
a little more force and he wanted us to
give him some credit Lakers have made
their last 5 flat 6
time out Phoenix McGee's 9 for 9 and
here come the Lakers time he gave it up
to Drummond usually make the right play
in that regard Bucky with a one-handed
slam dunk that's the eighth two suits
for to cool down a bit early days guitar
and it's stolen away passing lane kcp
another assist for coos he's looking to
geta his first double digit of comes
down it up and easily hammers it home
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Square Garden crowd as he throws to the
right will happen if you're the net you
want to make sure you put a full-court
pressure you don't want anybody to be
free to just rip it up and shoot
[Applause]
I just talked about that's why you pick
up and you don't allow anybody to just
have freedom get off
what ku is just drilling it up stepping
it across half court and drilling it
absolutely everything
three Kiku's before LeBron found them
beautifully in stride left-wing head
coos finishes to start this third
quarter LeBron another assist coot
Engels averaging almost five and a half
assists per game second on the team
behind Ricky Rubio who's my fax what hit
from straight on who's we got a really
nice ovation and the starting lineups
[Music]
Rubio playing off Rondo who's was gonna
launch another one and thanks son
another one okay now did he call window
either time cuz he came back up with a
smile on his face
Neto is come on makes this move swatted
by Kyle kushman what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content